and welcome to my video series of
pyrotechnics explained in five minutes
where I explain a concept in biological
technique in less than five minutes or
so if you haven't yet subscribe to my
channel hit the subscribe button and I'm
also present in an Academy which is
India's biggest online platform so if
you want to join on Academy you can use
my code in P 10 to get a 10% discount
now in this installment we're going to
talk about the ion exchange
chromatography the chromatography is a
simple technique to separate proteins
nucleic acids and many other small
molecules and biological materials from
a complex mixture another basic chrome
framework of chromatography is simple
the first step is equilibrium when you
run the equilibration buffer through the
column the equilibration buffer makes
the environment more feasible while the
protein is passing through the column so
the equilibration buffer moves through
the column and actually make the column
weight then you have a binding step when
you add your protein sample dissolved in
proper buffer you have to ensure that
the buffer does not deny your protein
structure because it might hinder with
proteins binding capability next step is
washing in the washing step on the
nonspecific interactions are washed away
and only the interactions which are very
specific and strong those are retained
in wash buffer we can use some
compositions of linked tea denaturant
which would get rid of all the weak in
interactions but not the strong
interaction in order to disrupt the weak
interaction we have to choose our
denaturants very careful after that the
stem is illusion in the illusion step
you dilute the protein of interest in a
sequential fashion and collect it in the
fluence room now another is in the flow
through you can understand which protein
is eluted
now let's take an proper example and
before that let's see how ionic
chromatography is unique so the ion
exchange chromatography use specific
anion exchange and cation exchange
resins this anion exchange and cation
exchange resins are charged particles so
cation exchange resins are negatively
charged so it would attract all the
positively charged around it but
initially it would be attracting all the
positively charged things which are
present in the buffer but eventually
when we put our ni 8 which is marked
here in orange it would replace the blue
ones which are the component of the
buffer and as a result it would exchange
the cation in expense of another cation
so that is why the cation exchange resin
is a negatively charged such that it can
attract the cations simply the cation
exchange resins example which is widely
used is carboxymethyl cellulose
carboxymethyl cellulose that are boxy
terminal is a negatively charged a
negatively charged group which is
attracting the cation towards it in case
of an ion exchange raising the core is
actually positive and the and islands
are negatively charged which is
replacing the negatively charged
particle which is present negatively
charged ion which is present in the
buffer a great example of the anion
exchange resin which is popularly used
is da cellulose which has a positively
charged in its tertiary amine group now
let's take a proper example in terms of
protein in terms of protein we don't
have one particular positive or one
particular negative charge a protein is
a mixture of all of these depending upon
the ratio of the positive and negative
charge it would interact differentially
with the catenation or an ion exchange
resin in this particular case the
protein has quite a lot of positive
charge that is why it is interacting
with the cation exchange resin which is
negatively charged now let's say we talk
about 3 or 4 different proteins and how
they are actually a jutted and how we
can separate them
so for illusion we can use a gradient of
a buffer or a Newton buffer which let's
say it has NaCl now NaCl has sodium as a
positively charged ion which would
really help us to elude the substance
the way illusion word is your positive
charged cation concentration is
increasing as a result that protein is
facing competition with these positively
charged cation and as a result the
protein is eluted so we can increase the
concentration of NaCl in a gradient like
fashion and at different time points
different Peaks or different fractions
are collected so let's try to understand
it pictorial each of these three
proteins are binding to the cation
exchange resin now these three proteins
has different degree of positive and
negative charge the blue one has the
highest amount of positive charge
followed by the orange and the green has
the least amount of positive charge so
whenever we increase the sodium
concentration a little bit what happens
the green one gets in Newton's first
because it has the weakest possible
interaction with the cation exchange
regime then the orange one would be
eluted still the blue one would be
attached because it has quite a lot of
positive charge which can still interact
with the cation exchange resin we need
very high concentration of salt or
concentration of sodium to elude the
protein in this particular example the
elseís then by changing the salt
concentration in a gradient like fashion
we can give you different protein at
different time points and we can really
fashion them according to our need and
this is how an exchange chromatography
works I hope this video was informative
and really quick so if you liked this
video give a thumbs up don't forget to
like share and subscribe and do leave a
comment how do you like my videos
because it gives me a lot of positive
motivation to make more such videos
thank you